okay as you know between Deacons the
slow played three matches in 1954 1957
and 1958 I want to show you a game from
1957 it was 17 game between it played
for white smooth slow played public so
Knight f3 Knight f6 g3 mg6 c4 c6 Bishop
g2 Bishop g7 d4 Castle kingside Knight
c3 d5 what is the name of opening now I
don't play defense C takes d5 C takes d5
Knight e5 why this move was good very
well so we have outpost gua on e5 I was
thrown in our Knight is thrown in the
center only Phi squad if open protect
this night so it's a good move for white
b6
what white should play here
Bishop g5 who I decided to play why why
I decided didn't make a so and play
Bishop g5
so if for example in this position white
omen what do I do this should take stuff
6th and 9th XD 500 Bishop takes d5 right
so we develop our Bishop to g5 and we
have tactical idea here okay good we
should be seven to defend the pawn on d5
now what
why should play yes Roxy one that's very
interesting move Knight e4 what we do
here take the nine D takes d4 Bishop f4
correct move f6 Knight suppose natural
move a5 and E 3 X equal but white played
in this position Bishop takes f6 Bishop
takes f6 he decided to exchange the
bishop on the night because pawn on d5
Evan gives big that's why he decided to
exchange it and black cannot develop
night from b8f knight c6 you can take
with the bishop pawn on d5
if 97 maybe what will it play if 97 for
example castle still Roxy one was
correct move but if Castle 97 and we
have choice Bishop takes d5 Knight takes
d5 so what if for example 1985 we didn't
calculate this so with Bishop takes D
file
yeah
Bishop takes
Bishop takes
and we want one right but if Knight
takes d5
take the Rue Queen takes that's when in
position provide right so what's valley
between it decided to exchange them
bishop on the night because night on big
has no job so so he pushed eastex it's
much slower in this position to defend
the pawn between achmed castle yes but
the roxy one was better again is xf4
your idea yeah so it's a typical idea of
middle game and of course the main idea
to defend the night only file if Bishop
takes if I what value do y f takes if I
open air file and okay good with towels
yes we don't give but actually we cannot
say that it's possible on d5 because we
have pawn only two motto Katie I can
push it in the future and open the
vision for example change the lights who
has bishops hotels some slow played
Bishop g7 now rooks even f6 to attack
the knight only five and Knight should
go back every knight c6 now you can
develop our night right if we to defend
the pawn on d4 and what is the best move
for black here so this of a sex we could
calculate rook F 2
okay it's interesting idea and typical
idea but in this position why they have
a better move so you feel that bishop
bishop on e6 a knight on c6 are weak
right so how we can use it I can take
the cone on before Knight takes d5 yes
that's interesting idea Knight takes d5
if he takes d5 rook takes this so you
want the pond if Queen takes d5 95 was
the idea take the knight so knight on c6
is weak after Bishop a6 what black
should play instead bishop Mystics Roxy
same idea to put the rope on open file
and to develop the roof because we are
sure that we should develop a look to
see it's chloride so it's better to
develop that piece which here for
example once crowd because maybe we will
play King his seven maybe Queen d7 in
the future we don't know exactly right
now and it's eco opposition but in this
position smooth slope played Queen d7
rook F 2 was interesting without moon
Bishop e6 the same idea to double the
rook on C file Knight a5 for example be
free to stop knight c4 rook c8 Bishop F
on your area F knight c6 rook F to see
to Tahlequah but it was interesting
so in this position between decided to
move we need to unblock should blame
night a file to put the night on c4
squad
for example be free maybe night every
and every square would be week
so why should plain' ID - Brooke a ch4
night c4 Knight takes rook takes and
defi stow equal but in this position how
I didn't play Knight d2 why plate h4
immediately so it's a little early
and what welcome to a homemade c4 stron
whoo g4 was interesting idea if I
decided to attack on the Kin side should
push an album and retry maybe in the
future Lucchesi Rock Fe one visual basic
screen f2 b5 actually better position
for black but I decided to play Bishop
h3 in this position
now what we do so how you can use open C
file yes Luke I see it
why should exchange the snide nidus
Turks h5 look c7 look after rock I've
said and the rock h2 is interesting
provider Queen f7 H takes H takes it's
still better position for black but some
slow didn't play the smooth he played 96
immediately without Roxy it in this
position which was not correct because
white can push h5 in this position
rocky 8h takes H takes Knight h4 Queen
f7 Queen g4 and white I have some
counter-attack on the kingside kin h7
look of to was idea Lucas to to use open
h1
so 96 was to Paso but between ik decided
to play King h2 which was bad move
because if I pushed the pony it's on h4
of course the main idea to push h5 and
open H file in the future and maybe to
play rook F 2 and Luke h2
but after King H 2 Black Rock the scroll
on h2 and Luke H 1 and can go back it's
too slow
a5 now your idea
it's my slow death so what do I should
play here so the Queen c2 is better here
I woke up c h5 to attack the pawn on d6
clean up 7h take jisuk stage takes a for
something like this but still better
position for back so connector was
mistaken
but can use it but in this position
between ik played rukka v1b file it was
interesting for white to play a 4-bit
Excel for Quincy - a freebie takes a
free rock FC Queen a - Andrew case
expose area double the rooks on C file
white grade 91 what will he do who like
him before that pushed v5 was the day
before now black has in more space on
the queenside and still one to the wall
Bishop to e6 qua so night after now what
Misha bases quindi one
but the rook F see it because maybe you
will need Europe on the 8th in the
future because you began to push the
pawns on the Queen side but the rookin
f8 has no job
ok and now what white should play in
this position rook c5 without post crown
on seed file so why not Roxy fine and
what black should play Knight b7 we
should take take and it's better
position for black but as familia it was
better to play for white the rook c5
because the difference is that in this
position white took immediately and
night on this success batten then on b7
scrum so from one point of view we lost
the tempo but night on b7 s person ok 92
was interesting as a year to stop night
c4 Knight e4 also a for Bishop a farm
out to exchange the bishops Knight takes
a farm
Bishop f8 stop button because black has
drawn the rook on C file and most based
on the Queen side and scroll on c4 evil
Bishop f1 immediately Bishop takes up on
the rook takes the fun and what black
should pay him yeah twin sister to
double the pieces on C file and what is
main area up to clean c6 yes black can
play Queen c2 in the future okay very
well rocky one was correct mu was the
idea of the Quincy to clean it too and
the Queen takes the to rook takes it to
white through can defend the pawns on
BitTorrent data on the second rank 94
for example might be still better
position for black but maybe while has
some chance to make a draw in this
position why I decided to play Knight d3
now what black should play
f Queen c2 Queen takes rook takes and
what why do you do which more a lot F -
yes
so rook takes Knight takes would work
and play him
Knight c4 of course I take the pawn on
which is the Forgotten tag the spawn 91
very well kidnapped seven to improve of
a cane to vibrate be free hyung which is
weak why
I'm just eating there okay yes because
bono NATO is weak and why that bad
construction now scroll and see if it is
a big white and black can use it in the
future so what do black should play be
freer was area take the night so - its
ground go back yeah Kinji 294 it's good
more 94 91 a 5d takes e5 f takes yes
open the bishop night of - Knight c3 F
takes Bishop takes Knight have d3
genious ex-nazi one King a five and it's
better position for and better and
gainful black because they have better
King better construction on the Queen
side draw knight on c3 Knight on c1 a
special should protect the community
but SMU's law decided to play in this
position h5
so what do I should play him fight me to
him through the night from a forest
ground Mighty One
also was area maybe 93 95 then 97 of 94
so if 5d takes e5 f takes d5 f takes
Bishop takes Knight f3 Bishop f6 Knight
have to something like this Knight d5
before D takes Knight takes Knight c3
Knight take skin takes and 94-92 was
idea Knight c4
but between a great teenage free 94g for
stoking g2 was better provide to go back
and what black should play here
Knight c3 was correct if Knight takes c3
be take serious we have passed pawn on
c5 okay what do I should play 91 very
well now how we can use several possible
if I we should develop we should improve
our Bishop and open this diagonal night
see - why not kinesics to improve the
King and it should be winning game right
okay yes but smooth law didn't play
Knight c3 he took the pawn on g4 kin
take g4 teeny 7 again was better move to
improve the King he played a 5k niche
free Bishop f6 Kim G - again was better
for white turn through the king but why
I decided to play Knight even not even
King g7 what is the main idea of the
small yes so we have a weak bone on a to
which we can attack like an attack this
bone and we need to make an hour weeks
cloud upon because it will be difficult
to win right if we have on the one with
pawn on a - which you can attack because
white can defend
so after keen age 16 hy we can win the
pawn on h4
nida free Knight c3 Knight takes B takes
and it was interesting for white to push
before here
and in this position after B takes
Ephraim it was 40 moves and between the
growth move 91 and postpone postponed at
the game so after that we they analyze
this game at home with coaches from one
point of view but very interesting that
between ik was sure that it will be draw
and in the one in next day his coach
offered draw asthma slow but he didn't
accept it because he found very
beautiful idea for black so better move
was before in this position a takes
Knight X before King h6 a for Bishop d8
Knight c2 and to the white can make
grahyam but between ik rot nighty one
kin h6 92 Bishop e7 and why should play
a three in this position kin h5 before
was idea to trade the pawns on a file
because if you want to make a draw it's
good for you to exchange the pawns in
the endgame right if you don't want to
make a draw what should you do don't
exchange if you don't want
okay it's a dream because night on c2
and we have that class which we cannot
exchange it but it's interesting to play
a 4 B 5 for example Bishop d8 and night
before so equal but between ik didn't
understand this idea that he needs to
exchange the phones on a file and push a
three before he played King g3 kin h5
kin f3 can take search for and talipes
what is the main idea for black right
now 91 yes it can be yes it's gonna be a
super strong and smooth slow fun very
interesting idea that kin can go from
the hillside to the Queen side like you
said King H freakin h2 kim jiwon kin the
fun but should cut the king of course
bish bish ho before this room f2 [ __ ]
and it kidney - Kim G - so g5 he push
first of all and F takes with a dr kim
takes Knight c2 bishop distance to cut
the king on f4 scroll so he has time for
this night a one teenage for again 92
teenage free night a one King H -
Kenneth - now what black should play
Bishop g3 check in every year
Bishop h4 very well might see to Kim
Jiwan you see Keaney - Kim G - yes yes
many times why should push this so in
this position that was interesting a
free and if teenage - enough - but here
Bishop e7 so dangerous young before and
it's important to play which movie on
pro black
Bishop h4 Keaney - yes a four because
after eight eggs before it takes before
black-white health chance to make a draw
so a4 and it's it should be a winning
position because Bishop can stop that
pawn postponed
Bishop did you will see what happened in
the game he pushed a three before but it
was too late
so he'll eat you in this position what
work should play
Kinji - not a one
okay it can do instead night a one candy
free what black can play here
what if kin Ephraim can take the free
candy - before King take Sofia
okay I'll play a four
this update
yeah yeah so maybe in this position we
should take the pawn on before a takes
night eggs and play maybe King f1 was
bad hyung I'm idea but we have in some
lines chance to move a 1v1 if King takes
the freaking eat - so same ok before
stop a foe
okay what if Bishop e7 idea to stop
before and after can see free to Mookie
need to so why they are not good move
okay
a takes before
I think if you will take it should be
winning position no no I mean the better
for black because we have fun and better
kin
okay everybody has to some chance to
make the robot so what do you want to
play yes a for not good it's better to
push okay so before right now a takes I
think you guys should take night eggs
before and maybe hyung can you want
if king of to 90 to 92 kin D 1 B 4 B
should be kidney too but it was very
interesting idea so my day one this
should eat 792 kingi 391 Bishop d8 night
c2 Bishop f6 and now it's fun so white
cannot move with the night because a for
and the big pawn on d4 also cannot move
with keen because kidnap free but Kin
Kin d3 was better move again no idea
a free between ik push the pawn Bishop
e7
before a four or I don't exchange the
pawns 91 Bishop g5 night c2 and Bishop
f6 again so you can use it many times in
the endgame King be free enough to night
a1 bishop date night c2 Bishop g5 b5 and
Bishop date night before we should be
six nights it will be super fun after
night egg before what we do
gave me wrong yes of course yes because
the main idea for black was all endgame
to move the Duke inside to work in the
skin side to vacuum inside so kindy one
can see one can be too if Kinzie free
your idea I can eat you and can take it
III and push a phone so in this position
between a green line so it was very
beautiful and game and what did you
study
what do you remember after this platform
yes soaked in can be active not only in
the center in the endgame but it's
possible to move with the Queen side to
the keen side to the Queen side what
else
yes you should push past pawns in the
endgame and past bones are really strong
it's a big problem for our opening okay
what else yeah so Bishop is very strong
then it's open files and the bishop has
diagonal right and tonight is better for
example Knight has some corset position
and outpost cross but in this position
it was difficult for white to do
something because Knight should start
the pawn on C free yeah yes we should
calculate a lot and remember in the
endgame
you cannot say that it's better for
white or black you should understand
that in the end game it's winning
position illusion positional let's draw
any ship calculated and and you should
think before to go
to the endgame and also if you want to
make draw you should exchange the pawns
it will be easy for you to make a draw
if you don't want to make a draw if you
want to win the game
push the phone a4 like in this end game
and try to make an hour week pawn or
squad and don't trade that one